>>> BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
THE HOUSE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
STANDING DOWN ON SOME OF ITS
DEMANDS FOR SOME OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE
DOCUMENTS.
THIS, AFTER PUSHBACK
INTERESTINGLY FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CONVINCING THE
COMMITTEE TO SCALE BACK THAT
REQUEST.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION APPEARS TO HAVE
TOLD THE COMMITTEE ITS REQUESTS,
ON SOME FRONTS, MAY HAVE GONE
TOO FAR.
JESSICA SCHNEIDER IS OUT FRONT
AND JOINS US NOW.
EXPLAIN WHY.
WHAT ARE THESE DOCUMENTS?
>> WELL, THESE ARE DOCUMENTS
FROM THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL AND IT MEANS THAT FOR
NOW, POPPY, THE COMMITTEE WON'T
BE GETTING HUNDREDS OF THESE
PAGES FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
SO, OUR TEAMS ACTUALLY REVIEWED
SEVERAL LETTERS FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE LAWYERS.
THEY ARE TELLING THE COMMITTEE
THESE PARTICULAR RECORDS DON'T
TOUCH ON ANYTHING DO WITH
JANUARY 6th.
SO IN RESPONSE, THE COMMITTEE
HAS WIGTD DRAWN THEIR REQUEST
FOR NOW.
AND IT DOES APPEAR TO BE THE
FIRST TIME THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
HAS PUSHED BACK ON HANDING OVER
THESE TRUMP DOCUMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
BIDEN'S LAWYERS ARE SAYING THEY
WANT TO KEEP THE RECORD SECRET
TO, IN THEIR WORDS PRESERVE THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF DISCUSSIONS
AND ADVICE AROUND THE
PRESIDENCY.
WE ACTUALLY GOT RESPONSE FROM
THE COMMITTEE LATE TONIGHT
SIGHING CIAING THEY MAY ACTUALLY
RENEW THIS REQUEST.
AND REMEMBER, OF COURSE, THERE
IS STILL THAT FIGHT THAT IS NOW
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT ABOUT
WHETHER 700 OTHER DOCUMENTS FROM
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE WILL
ACTUALLY GO TO THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE.
BUT THOSE DOCUMENTS, OF COURSE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES APPROVE OF
HANDING OVER.
THIS IS A MINOR SETBACK BUT IT
COMES AS THE COMMITTEE IS
REVEALING ITS PLANS FOR 2022.
SOURCES ARE TELLING OUR TEAM
THAT THERE IS A PLAN FOR AN
INTERIM PUBLIC REPORT THAT COULD
BE RELEASED THIS SUMMER.
AND THEN, A FINAL REPORT BY THE
FALL.
AND PLUS, WE ARE SEEING THAT
PLANS ARE IN THE WORKS FOR
PUBLIC HEARINGS IN 2022 BUT NO
EXACT TIMELINE ON THAT.
SO, YOU KNOW, POPPY, THE
COMMITTEE HAS CONDUCTED, UP TO
THIS POINT, MUCH OF ITS WORK
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
SO THIS COULD BE A CHANCE IN
2022 FOR THE PUBLIC REALLY TO
GET A GLIMPSE OF ALL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS UNCOVERED IN ITS
INTERVIEWS WITH WHAT THEY SAY IS
HUNDREDS OF WITNESSES, SO FAR.
POPPY.
>> JESSICA SCHNEIDER, THANK YOU
FOR THE REPORTING TONIGHT.
AND NOW, I WANT TO BRING IN
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN JAMAL
BOWMAN OF NEW YORK.
HE IS CALLING ON PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO MAKE JANUARY 6th A DAY OF
NATIONAL HEALING.
WRITING IN A LETTER TO BIDEN,
QUOTE, I URGE YOU TO USE YOUR
EXECUTIVE POWER TO HIGHLIGHT THE
INJUSTICE OF JANUARY 6th AND
MAKE SURE THE TRAUMA IT CAUSED
IS NOT LOST TO HISTORY.
GOOD EVENING, CONGRESSMAN, AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> OF COURSE.
GOOD EVENING.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> HAS THE PRESIDENT OR WHITE
HOUSE RESPONDED TO YOUR LETTER?
>> NOT AS OF YET BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS, AND
THERE IS INTEREST THERE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT -- IT'S
VERY APPARENT WHEN WE HAVE --
WHEN YOU SEE OVER 800,000 PEOPLE
DEAD FROM COVID, THE TRAUMA OF
THE 2020 ELECTION, THE TRAUMA OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
WE HAVE THE CONVERGENCE OF THESE
COMPLEX TRAUMAS, AND WE HAVEN'T
PAUSED, AS A NATION, TO
COLLECTIVELY HEAL IN RESPONSE TO
THESE TRAUMAS.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO, YOU KNOW, GET BACK
TO -- TO WORK AND GET THE
ECONOMY GOING.
AND THAT'S FINE.
BUT WITHOUT A PAUSE, WITHOUT
REFLECTION, WITHOUT COLLECTIVE
HEALING, OUR ECONOMY ISN'T GOING
TO TAKE OFF IN THE WAY THAT IT
NEEDS TO AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE SOME OF THE HARM
THAT IS HAPPENING AMONGST OUR
KIDS AND AMONGST HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
SO THERE IS JUST A LOT OF
HEALING WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS THE PERFECT PERSON TO LEAD
THAT WORK.
>> I WANT TO TURN TO ANOTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN WASHINGTON
AND YOU TOUCHED ON IT WHEN YOU
MENTIONED THE ECONOMY AND SORT
OF BROADER ECONOMIC HEALING AND
AS THE FATE OF BIDEN'S DOMESTIC
AGENDA AND THE NEARLY $2
TRILLION BUILD BACK BETTER BILL,
DEMOCRATS -- SOME OF THEM -- ARE
NOW OPEN TO BREAKING IT UP INTO
SMALLER PIECES.
HERE IS WHAT TWO OF YOUR HOUSE
COLLEAGUES SAID ABOUT THAT.
>> IF WE CAN'T GET THE BILL IN
ITS ENTIRETY PASSED, THEN YEAH
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OPTIONS FOR
HOW WE CAN GET SEPARATE PIECES
PASSED.
>> TO SORT OF HOLD BACK AND PUT
THE FOOT ON THE BRAKE RIGHT NOW
AND PARCEL OUT WHO GETS IN AND
WHO GETS LEFT OUT I THINK IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> WHERE DO YOU STAND ON
BREAKING IT UP?
>> UM, I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
APPROACH OF BREAKING IT UP.
THIS IS A BILL THAT'S BEEN
TOGETHER FOR SEVERAL MONTHS.
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH WORK TO GET
THE BILL TO WHERE IT IS.
IT WAS A MUCH LARGER BILL, AS WE
KNOW.
AND IT'S BEEN UNDER ATTACK FROM
SPECIAL INTERESTS AND SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE A BIT MORE
CONSERVATIVE.
WE CANNOT LEAVE WOMEN BEHIND.
WE CANNOT LEAVE CHILDREN BEHIND.
WE CANNOT LEAVE PEOPLE OF COLOR
BEHIND.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE CLIMATE
CRISIS, AND WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
THE CARE ECONOMY AND OUR
SENIORS.
AND HISTORICALLY, WE CONTINUE TO
LEAVE THESE GROUPS BEHIND AND
THIS HAS BEEN MY CONCERN FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS.
>> WE WERE LOOKING BACK AT SOME
OF THE INTERVIEWS YOU DID RIGHT
WHEN YOU WON YOUR SEAT AND IT
WAS ONE YEAR AND ONE DAY AGO, ON
THIS NETWORK, ON STATE OF THE
UNION WHEN YOU SAID THIS.
>> WE CANNOT COMPROMISE WHEN IT
COMES TO WHETHER THE NEEDS OF
THE PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT,
PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY, PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS, PEOPLE ARE JOBLESS,
POVERTY RATES ARE WAY TOO HIGH,
AND MY FIGHT IN CONGRESS IS
GOING TO BE WITH THE PEOPLE OF
OUR DISTRICT TO MAKE SURE WE
DEAL WITH THOSE ISSUES
EXPLICITLY AND DIRECTLY WITHOUT
COMPROMISE.
>> I WONDER IF IT'S BEEN EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT THAN YOU THOUGHT
THEN TO LEGISLATE AND GET THINGS
DONE IN CONGRESS?
>> WELL FIRST OF ALL, I AM VERY
HAPPY THAT I HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENT WITH MY POSITION, SO
THAT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR --
>> THERE IS ALWAYS TAPE TO PLAY
IT BACK.
>> UM, IT -- IT HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT.
IT HAS BEEN CHALLENGING.
BUT I HAVE BEEN ENCOURAGED
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, HOUSE
LEADERSHIP -- SPEAKER PELOSI,
CHAIRMAN JEFFRIES, THE
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE ALL BEEN ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH PUSHING -- WITH
GETTING BUILD BACK BETTER DONE.
THE NAME BUILD BACK BETTER COMES
FROM THE UNDERSTANDING THAT,
HISTORICALLY, WE HAVE LEFT THESE
COMMUNITIES BEHIND.
AND NOW IS THE TIME NOT TO MAKE
THE SAME MISTAKES THAT WERE MADE
BY FDR AND THE NEW DEAL.
THE NEW DEAL WAS GREAT.
IT GAVE US SOCIAL SECURITY.
WE RESPONDED TO THE MOMENT BUT
WE LEFT PEOPLE OF COLOR BEHIND.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE REDLINED
BLACK COMMUNITIES THAT STILL
HAVEN'T RECOVERED IN TERMS OF
THE ISSUE OF WEALTH INEQUALITY.
SO, IN ORDER TO HEAL AS A
COUNTRY -- YEP, GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY, I
HEAR YOU ON ALL THAT.
BUT I DO WANT TO PUSH BACK, AND
JUST ASK YOU ABOUT COMPROMISE
BECAUSE DAVID AXELROD -- FORMER
SENIOR ADVISER TO PRESIDENT
OBAMA -- WROTE A REALLY
INTERESTING PIECE YESTERDAY IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
TALKING ABOUT THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AND THE LESSON OF GOING
WITH IT, EVEN WHEN YOU DON'T GET
EVERYTHING YOU WANT.
REMEMBER?
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THEY DROPPED THE PUBLIC OPTION
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T GET ALL
THE DEMOCRATS ONBOARD AND THEY
GOT SOMETHING.
HE SAID YOU CAN'T ALWAYS GET
WHAT YOU WANT, SO GET WHAT YOU
CAN TO PARAPHRASE ROOSEVELT,
IT'S TIME FOR A RENDEZVOUS WITH
REALITY AND TO FIGHT FOR WHAT IS
POSSIBLE.
IS THERE NOT A LESSON THERE?
>> OF COURSE, THERE IS.
BUT HERE IS THE THING.
BLACK PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS
COMPROMISING.
LATINOS, ALWAYS COMPROMISING.
IMMIGRANTS, ALWAYS COMPROMISING.
THE POOR, ALWAYS COMPROMISING.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT COMPROMISE,
THIS IS ABOUT SPECIAL INTERESTS
CONTROLLING HOW WASHINGTON
WORKS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FOSSIL FUEL
LOBBY, THE PHARMACEUTICAL LOBBY,
BIG MONEY IN POLITICS
CONTROLLING HOW WE GOVERN, HOW
WE LEGISLATE, AND FRAMING THE
DEBATE.
I LIVE IN A DISTRICT WHICH IF WE
WERE A NATION, WE WOULD HAVE THE
EIGHTH WORST ECONOMIC INEQUALITY
IN THE WORLD.
WHEN YOU ARE BLACK OR BROWN IN
THIS DISTRICT, YOU ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE POOR.
YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF VIOLENCE.
YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO GO TO
UNDERFUNDED SCHOOLS AND YOU ARE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE HOUSING THAT
IS DEVALUE